moins de 4 ans byron avions pas parlé
les moqueries émission mon caddie mais
quand même quand même ne sommes pas des
animaux
nous sommes des êtres humains messieurs
et madame souvent les congolais qui tu
es ce sont des survivants
on peut les appeler ainsi après une vie
de labeur à épandre les engrais à la
main respirait les pesticides à pleins
poumons plonger leurs bras dans les
bains de fongicides programme était l'un
d'eux mêmes g et et déjoue landais un
journal el maghrabi et l'homme et nadège
où l'avait un jour ma lettre chaque lame
anyama et libérale et bagnères
vomissements c'est le double mvp doubler
toute la vie - s'est doublée
quand j'ai joué mes temps paul j vos
côtés des mots car mal de casse at il
déploré en battant dit j'aimerais qu'on
leur met même pas ça ça me passe à
rester debout longtemps et puis voilà la
réalité conduit à la modalité mémoire
ceux qui sont là parlent pour ceux qui
n'ont plus la force de sortir de chez
eux et pour une trentaine de camarades
décédés récemment de cancers et autres
maladies
leurs témoignages poignants déroule une
même liste de maladies non élucidées on
vise aujourd'hui avant tout c est
reconnue maladie professionnelle dans la
banane quoi on peut pas dieu sait
c'est du hasard parce que pratiquement
tous les ouvriers agricoles ont les
mêmes symptômes
ce qui me choque dans cette histoire
c'est le mensonge la profitation et le
naïf pas pourquoi on nous a menti
on nous a fait quoi comme mon beauf
c'était pour aller plus vite
c'était pour gagner plus qu'est ce que
je pouvais faire il fallait nous ma mère
mes frères
le mouchoir que je l'attaché la dette
je m'étais saumonée et puis j'ai
travaillé désormais chacun prend
brutalement la mesure d'un
emprisonnement généralisée c'était dur
d'entendre ces témoignages je pensais
pas si je pensais venir à nier mieux
comme ça mais attend des trucs aussi
horrible car c'est poignant c'est
touchant kouassi mais non je me rends
compte quand elle disait que la malle et
je vois beaucoup d'autres personnes à ce
même problème
et quand elle a vu ça fait longtemps
qu'ils avaient oublié qu'elle n'aurait
pas dû et voyez qu'ils étaient mes goûts
des additions de plus jeune qu'elle très
abîmée veulent poser la question mais
moi ils se gardent ça et quand on
attendait le témoignage
alors on s'est dit ah d'accord
mais franchement avec le soutien discret
du cncp du modemas dupe et quelle s et
leurs avocats
les anciens de bausch est entendu au
moins être reconnu et prises en charge
pour leurs soins